Makkah and Arabia but the year 570.
Mercury is important for two reasons one
the Kaaba is there an ancient temple
built to worship God and two Muhammad
peace be upon him was born in Mecca
Now problem I can't shame Muhammad
because it wouldn't be right I'll tell
you why in a bit but in the meantime his
name in Arabic nice
back in the day Mecca was a lawless
place the only way to be safe was to
have backup lots of Rich Big Brothers
who'd beat up anyone who got in your way
so the place was ruled by the most
powerful families who could do pretty
much what they wanted
and religion didn't help by this time
the Kaaba had been filled to overflowing
with 360 Idols that did nothing to help
anyone so it was a tough place to grow
up if like Muhammad you were a poor
orphan and believing just one God you
couldn't see like the Jews and the
Christians he called him Allah the god
in Arabic there
Muhammad's dad died before he was even
born and his mom died when he was just
six so he was brought up by his
grandfather Abdul muttalib and then when
he died too by his uncle abutalu wow you
have the respect for the Secretary of
families so Muhammad was safe for the
time being
Muhammad started out as a shepherd and
then became a businessman traveling
about buying and selling stuff for rich
clients
when he did some work for a rich Widow
called Khadija she was so impressed by
his honesty in school that they ended up
getting married and for a while it
looked like Muhammad was going places
well he was but not how you think
every year in the month of Ramadan
different calendar different names for
the months there was a big party around
the cover when people made sacrifices
Ramadan I thought Ramadan was a Muslim
holiday right so what's up with all
these gods they um this is like what
they idolized as the gods so like how
some religions have a god of different
things that's that's what they were like
I think that's what it was that they
were saying yeah there were all these
different Idols like we've talked about
the pagans worshiping the sun
various things as Gods but back up 10
seconds and then she said something
about the month of Ramadan every year in
the month of Ramadan different calendar
different names for the months there was
a big party around the cover when people
made sacrifices to the idols Muhammad
hated it so he'd get okay damn they used
to make sacrifices madon was just
something that was happening anyway
before Islam it looks like they were
doing Godless activities around Mecca
yeah okay damn tattle of town and sleep
in a cave he'd found on top of a nearby
Mountain
one night Muhammad's praying to Allah
there's an angel you might say Gabriel
standing right in front of him Reid says
the angel but Muhammad couldn't read no
schools you see Jubilee keeps on at him
three times he says read then he grabs
hold of Muhammad and Wham again it's
like Muhammad's learned the words off by
heart
so he recites the message out loud
read in the name of your lord who
created man from a drop of blood read
for your lord is most generous he who
taught by them and you can go to that
mountain right like I think that's a
like a legit historical landmark that
people can go to isn't that what the
three Muslims said and he said one of
them went there and felt like something
he did say some he said say he went to
one of the one of the special you know
places where Muhammad was I don't know
if it was this one oh I don't remember
have you ever had something with like a
dream so how he couldn't understand
language and then he suddenly understood
it did you ever have that in a dream or
something where something like didn't
make any sense to you or you couldn't
and then you either had a dream or
something like that and then it started
making sense music
um I I can I can I have written songs in
my dreams that I know I have never heard
and you woke up and I don't know how to
write it down and I I and I they they
are lost it's happened two I think it's
happened three times two that I can
remember for sure and it told me like
the thing is in my head Ed I feel like
if I studied music and I really dug into
it that I could actually write music and
I can't I know I can't read music I
can't write music I can't play any
instruments but in my dream I have
written new songs that I know did not
exist that's correct and it drives me
crazy and I and I wonder if there's some
sort of message there that I should be
doing yeah it was just a straight Banger
could have taken taken you out of the
hood you'll never know I had that with
Italian I said where I couldn't
understand Italian and then I had a
dream and it just like made sense
afterwards wow it was weird like I
couldn't understand conjugations for the
life of me like first second third
person and then you know I was trying to
learn it or sort of I didn't really care
about school and then I had a dream and
then I just got like so much better at
languages and like I was kind of with
all my like on the same wavelength as my
friends where we were all just dumb
asses in the class and then I was like
the smartest
yeah the matter of days I was really
good at it weird stuff how that happens
and taught man what's he is there a
reason for that it was a message from
Allah God was speaking to him just like
he'd spoken to the prophets in the
Jewish and Christian holy books which
meant he was a prophet too
the messages continue for the rest of
Muhammad's life Allah gave him the words
to say and the prophet recited them the
words were written down by his friends
and years later they were collected
together and became the Muslim holy book
the Quran which means recitation because
Muhammad recited it you see anyway that
was much later so back to the night of
power Muhammad tells his family then his
friends and eventually everyone about
Allah that he's the one and any God that
he wants everyone to be treated fairly
and long story short it didn't go down
well with the ruining families of Mecca
who would like things just the way they
were thank you very much you see Islam
earns obedience to Allah and Muslim
means someone who obeys Allah and the
ruling families didn't want anyone
obeying anyone else
so the people who believed in Muhammad's
message the Muslims were given a hard
time some were even tortured and killed
a few of them managed to escape to
abyssinia Ethiopia
but most were stuck in Mecca
Muhammad also had to cope with the death
of his wife and then just a few weeks
later his uncle too
damn that's feeling very down he went to
the carpet to pray to Allah one night
then the weirdest thing happened jibril
ill turns up sits him on a winged horse
called alborak and flies him all the way
from Mecca to Jerusalem he prays with
all the prophets who have ever lived
then he's taken up to the Heavens to
chat with some of them did they just say
he won a winged horse flew to Jerusalem
and then prayed with all the prophets
does that mean that he was with Jesus in
them Jesus and Moses Elijah so it's like
how much do we take as like truth like
that legit happened or what if it was
like a psychedelic experience or
something because you know what I mean
yeah no they're good questions and I'm
sure that that there are some there are
some Scholars who could answer them but
they did talk about how you know
Muhammad was clear on staying away from
you know psychedelic not necessarily
psychedelics but no I know I know it's
like you pick up the phone and you're
not putting it down you're you're you
know
that means you're acknowledge that
you're like seeing those forces look if
you believe that Moses parted the Red
Sea that Jesus could raise the dead heal
the blind to heal lepers you know what
why not believe that Muhammad could fly
you know that a winged horse took him
somewhere yeah I mean who who knows I
mean that just sounds wild you know what
I mean and I'm not saying that about
maybe it was a pterodactyl I don't know
wait let's keep going though prophets
and then into Paradise itself so but
like I'm saying like with all other
prophets does not mean that he was with
Jesus then does that mean Jesus was back
but was that like was Jesus really back
or was it like some Star Wars [ __ ] where
you you know like you're with like the
ghost of Yoda and everyone else you know
definitely some Star Wars [ __ ] right
because I think if Jesus really if it
was Jesus's actual second coming then
then the world would have known and I
also think that there have been other
highly documented and verified sightings
of
um Saints and the mother Mary in in
Fatima and there have been you know
Angels like we're met multiple people
saw them and multiple people witnessed
with miracles in more Modern Day history
so it's not that far-fetched to think
that he sat with the prophets but Allah
tells Muhammad to pray five times a day
and to stay strong
he's returned to Jerusalem and then
flies back to the Kaaba in Makkah we
call it the night journey and Muslims
still argue whether it was a real
experience or a vision but whatever it
gave Muhammad a much needed even the
Muslims are arguing about that wow
that's wild I'd love to hear that I'd
love to hear educated crazy that that's
like the one thing I really question and
that's the same thing they do that's so
fascinating boost and just as well like
imagine it was just that crazy to
question whether or not [ __ ] Pegasus
came along and flew someone yeah but how
do you know what to believe with
religion a lot of the time you know
that's what I'm saying it's not that
crazy that it was yeah others questioned
it let's just keep going because there
were more tough times ahead
so there was this other city for
yotherim the people there heard about
Muhammad and his message and invited him
and his followers to join them
a few at a time the Muslims left Mecca
and made a dangerous journey across the
desert
which means migration
made a dangerous Journey
it's known as a Hijra which means
migration you know like birds do
Muhammad and a few of his friends stayed
in Makkah until everyone had got away
and then made plans for their own Escape
but the warning families wanted to kill
Muhammad while they still could to seven
sons one from each family was sent in
the middle of the night to stab the
prophet while he slept but he was way
ahead of them and when they burst into
the house Muhammad was gone
trackers were sent out to hunt him down
Muhammad and his best friend Abu Bakr
took a roundabout route to try and shake
off the pursuit but the trackers were
too good and slowly gained on them you
know that's so crazy to think about back
then that like the way you had to track
people I feel like back then you could
just go to a town Robert go to the next
town and like how is anyone gonna find
you how do you even explain what the
person looked like who did this thing
yeah how are they going to prove that
like that's wild that they're they're
going in Tracy that was really scared
that's why though um a lot of people a
lot of innocent people were convicted
were accused and convicted and hung or
whatever for for crimes they didn't
commit because that's something because
the leaders needed to solve the crime in
order to make everybody feel better and
so they'd be like he did it he looks
yeah oh look yeah six foot white guy yep
you did it and you'd be hanging in the
Town Square unfortunately which you know
really it's really sad so Muhammad and
Abu Bakr Hindi came and pray that no one
found them the truck has found the cable
right but they didn't bother going into
search there was no way Muhammad could
be inside they thought
there was a spider's web over their
mouth on the cave and a nesting bird at
the entrance he must have given them the
slip so off they went even Muhammad and
Abu Bakr protected by a spider and a
bird
what so did they say like he went in the
cave and there must have been a water
supply inside or something and then the
spider built it and the the bird like
they say that in the Quran do you think
that that was intentional to think that
he would I would think so otherwise how
would we know they say that everything
they know about it it must be the one
book and that was one thing we learned
from the Muslims the three Muslims is
that they said that everything's in one
book where in Christianity you know we
have a lot of different wow writings
fascinating Muhammad made it safely to
yakub which was renamed Medina or Nabi
the city of the Prophet but most people
just call it Medina but Muhammad's
worries weren't over yet
there were three big battles between the
Muslims and the mackens first the Battle
of brother when Muhammad and just 313
men placed 1 000 American soldiers
miraculously
the Muslims won
what were those numbers
332.000 American soldiers
miraculously the Muslims won
then there was a battle of ahead which
didn't go so well some of Muhammad's men
disobeyed his orders and ran off during
the battle to raid the mackin's camp and
so the Muslims were outmaneuvered
then there was a battle of the trench
Medina was protected on three sides by
mountains so when the macking forces
advanced in the city the Muslims just
starve a deep change the mukins made
camp that the weather was terrible
pouring rain put out their fires and
Howling winds blew down their tents
eventually they gave up and went back to
Mecca
it was all a bit embarrassing they were
losing the respect of the local tribes
who were flocking to join the Muslims
so a peace treaty was signed at her
debut but it wasn't long before the
muffins broke it
Muhammad decided that enough was enough
by now he had over 10 000 men so he led
them across the desert to Mecca the
ruling families realized they'd made a
huge mistake but it was too late all
they could do was surrender and hope
that the Muslim Army killed them quickly
but Muhammad said there should be no
more fighting
he rode into Makkah and went straight to
the Kaaba he circled it seven times
anti-clockwise and smashed all the idols
redecating the Kaaba to Allah and that's
why I'm not going to show you Muhammad
the Muslims wanted to make it totally
clear that they only worshiped the one
unseen God so they didn't have any
pictures of Muhammad in case anyone
thought he was an idol and they didn't
have any pictures of Allah because he's
like nothing on Earth so it would be
impossible to draw him anyway
wow so there you go how is that makes a
lot more sense to me to be honest like
because when I think of God and stuff I
don't think of like a person or
something like that I think of like a
force that's just everywhere that you
know you you can't see and you need to
tap into different things to really be
in touch with it um but God sent Jesus
as an extension of himself so that we
could see God in another human being and
and he sent him as a messenger to make
him more relatable and and that's what
that is about so I I don't know that I
and people have died in modern like in
recent years because they drew a picture
of Muhammad an extremists Muslims killed
them because of that and you know really
I know it's not fair to it's not fair to
you know this is where like the media
comes in and prints a picture of Muslims
in Islam but I would like to talk to a
non-violent Muslim and see what they see
what their thoughts are on that I'd like
to hear that I'd like to hear the three
Muslims take on that and how serious it
is and why I get it that they take
everything seriously but is it worth
killing somebody over because they they
created a cartoon image of Muhammad I
mean where's the love in that and I
don't think it takes away from God to
show his messenger so I just think it
makes I get what they're saying as it
makes them like an idol because you know
he's just the prophet he's just a
messenger he's not the one that you're
you know you're worshiping that like I I
kind of do get that I don't I don't I I
get that I get that Muhammad had
problems with Idols because he was
steeped in this ridiculous culture where
everyone was a complete [ __ ] it's not
about Muhammad no but no but but it is
because he had a problem it said you
know he he couldn't stand all the all
those false Idols he couldn't stand the
sacrifices and the and the ceremonies
around it so he himself probably chose
you know like he he didn't want his
image to ever overshadow God the way
their those other Idols did so I get I
get that like that's pretty cool of him
at the same time I don't understand why
you know it's it you have to be so
hell-bent on it that it's it's worth
killing people over yeah I was like I
was it was some good learning stuff
there's some good beats in the story
that I that I felt like we got something
out of that yeah but I have to say and
this this is gonna probably you know be
controversial but as I learn more about
Islam on the one hand the more I respect
it and the more I respect Muslims and I
really appreciate them for their
everything about it the culture or the
religion their discipline but it
actually is cementing and moving me even
closer and more serious into
Christianity so interesting because it's
making me study Christianity more too is
there an original copy of the Quran
somewhere uh let's see it is part of the
mingana collection of 3000 Middle
Eastern manuscripts cared for by the
Cadbury research library at the
University but that's like that's the
original Quran that's one of the
earliest it says look up go up one of
the earliest surviving fragments of the
Quran and one of only a handful of early
manuscripts of the Quran in the world to
have been radiocarbon dated so it's it's
an early fragment not I mean of course
it's not gonna exist in its totality
that's crazy though all right make sure
to follow my Instagram I'm doing a 100
giveaway to someone who follows and then
likes and comments on my recent post
I'll pop it up here and yeah hope you
win drop us up and a like if you're into
it all right yeah and the little bell if
you want oops
little bell if you want to get
notifications on when new videos coming
out for show for sure all right guys see
you soon
[Music]